[Music]
hey it's Stephanie I'm here at the
security booth where you'll find a wall
full of keys to a more secure cloud and
today I am joined here by Chris and he's
going to show us about his demo here let
us know what you do here so I'm Chris
Prevost I'm a group product manager with
the cloud security products portfolio
hey so we have a lot of products in
portfolio
and this particular Booth we're talking
about generative Ai and how we're using
that to make some of our Cloud security
products even better this is a super
exciting space again after the keynote
we saw a little sneak peek of the Mandy
and capabilities with Jenna ad but what
are you showing here today yeah so today
we're showing how we're using generative
AI to address three big problems in
security the first one is there's a lot
of stuff to look through in security so
we want to be able to try and find more
things generative AI is helping us to
dig through the massive data to try and
find the things that are really
interesting so that's the first thing
find more threats the second thing that
we're trying to do with it is we're
trying to address the problem that we
have in security of all these different
really great Security Solutions that
don't really work together very well
there's a lot of toil involved with that
so the second thing we're addressing is
toil we're using generative AI to maybe
basically Stitch those things together
faster and easier for us okay and then
the third thing and this is the biggest
problem I think in security okay so we
just don't have enough security people
who know things about the things to know
about so the talent shortage that's
another thing we're using generative AI
for so the idea is generative AI can
take really complicated things and
translate them and simplify them and
summarize them so that somebody who's
smart but maybe not a domain expert can
really get up to speed quick so those
are the three things we're trying to
address the generative AI in our Cloud
security products and in our demo we've
got a couple of examples awesome and
I'll just quick quickly click through
just a couple of these so in this first
example and there's about five of them
but I'll go quick
we're talking about the Mandate threat
intelligence product and so in this
solution what you can do is you can find
out all about the threat actors who
might be thinking about targeting you
and that helps you as a security
practitioner to figure out what are the
things I need to prioritize because
there's a lot of stuff to do in security
so using generative AI what we can do is
instead of hopping into the system and
saying oh let's find out about apt-43
that's a North Korean Nexus threat actor
and they also known as Lazarus group
what they tend to do is uh various
criminal activities which end up in them
stealing Bitcoins that they use to fund
other activities so not good oh wow but
they're pretty active and if you look in
the system you'll find that there's
maybe 11
000 hits of things that they're up to
identifiers that relate to them that's a
lot for one particular person to know
so you can use generative AI type in
apt-43 and it'll summarize all the data
that's in there about that particular
thread actor and give you kind of an
action plan okay this is what they do
this is what you should look for this is
what you need to do next
that's a really cool use of generative
AI addressing that Talent Gap second
thing this is our Chronicle solution
Chronicles are security information and
event management solution and
essentially what it does it gathers a
whole bunch of data from your
infrastructure and it and then our
security analysts can look through that
and try and figure out is there activity
in here that would indicate that a bad
guy is in our network doing bad things
and it can be pretty complicated so
we're using generative AI to make it
really easy so instead of having to know
all the details of how do I write the
right kind of a search query for this
system I can just use a natural language
search and that gets translated
automatically by generative AI into the
correct syntax for this particular
solution to find the details so
addressing the toil yeah in this
particular solution third thing this is
our security orchestration automation
platform uh and what this does is once I
find something bad in that big pool of
data now I need to figure out what am I
going to do with this should I go and
contain an endpoint or should I go do
some other activity patch of things
something like that
it can be a lot of data in here so what
we're using generative AI for is
basically summarize all this data in
this particular case so that the
security analyst can look at this and
say oh I think I need to go investigate
this next take these actions do this
other thing so again trying to make it a
little bit easier for the security
analysts to get their job done this
one's a really cool one this was in our
security Command Center in security
Command Center is our Cloud security
posture management solution so you load
things up into gcp you want to get
everything all set up get your VPC
parameter set up and your VMS and all
that kind of stuff but what if you made
a mistake uh-oh that's our security
Command Center come in play so I can do
is it can help you to figure out quickly
did you make a mistake when you
configured this thing is there some
threat actors that are poking at you
that you need to know about so basically
helps you keep eyes on glass for what's
going on in your Cloud environment gcp
sometimes it can be complicated though
because there's a lot of stuff in your
gcp environment and what this solution
does is attack path simulation in
security Command Center and what it does
is it basically shows you a step-by-step
path for how a bad guy could go from the
outside into your high value resources
so it's really cool but these can be
really complicated lots of different
steps that bad guy can take so we're
using generative AI to summarize well
what does this graph mean and what
should I do next so again kind of making
that easier for the security analyst
last thing is in our virus total
products the virus total is the world's
largest crowdsourced threat Intel
platform I mean it's massive there's
billions of bits and pieces of data in
there that a security analyst would use
to figure out is a bad guy in my network
okay but
what if it's the very first time that
this particular piece of malware has
ever been seen in the world
nobody in the world in the
crowdsourceful knows about this thing
yet but we're doing some super cool
generative AI we're basically taking
that piece of malware we're reading it
interpreting it and then translating it
into human language so you can
understand what it does so in this
example maybe nobody in the community
has ever seen this thing before but here
General is reading a second oh this is
malware we can see that it's going to do
this that that which is just like what
malware does yeah so super cool getting
ahead of the curve reducing toil in this
particular case you discover a lot there
but the way I see it is you're surfacing
data you are explaining it and wrangling
it explaining it and then enabling
people to take action exactly and it
seems like that's sort of the trend I
see with Cloud technology right it's
like we have the dashboards we're
overwhelmed with Dash words and we're
overwhelmed with information and ways to
visualize it but it's just that added
trying to keep up with the velocity of
what attackers are for example it's
exactly right we're trying to use the
machines to help us get ahead of that
yes right it's a cat and mouse game but
we're trying to win the race here you
got it thank you so much
foreign